speech can't be suppressed because of
the ideas that it expresses no matter
how offensive and wrong we might view
those ideas to be did police avert a
mass shooting in the picturesque
mountain town of whitefish montana when
they apprehended a young man following a
string of disturbing social media posts
a handful of citizens and activists
believe so we do a lot of hand wringing
and praying and calling for action after
school shootings here's a case where
potentially a school shooting was
averted
franciene Rustin is one of two rabbis
living in Flathead County and believes
that she was the target of the deranged
would-be shooter who ranted about
killing the Jews and schoolchildren on
his Twitter account that young man is
David Lenny O a 29 year old short-order
cook who moved to Montana a little over
a year ago so he could snowboard the
nearby slopes he lived out of his van
and apparently liked to tweet the case
works backwards because Presidents Day
weekend
the Copenhagen shooting happens he
engages with somebody on Twitter and
responds to something they said the
gunman fired dozens of shots into a
central Copenhagen cafe where an event
on freedom of expression was leased
gathering right now near the scene of
that deadly terrorist attack in the
Danish capital Copenhagen where it all
began on February 15 2015
the day after the shooting attacks on a
Copenhagen cafe and synagogue a
publicist and political activist named
Jonathan Hudson was tweeting about the
tragedy when he noticed an account
called psychic dog talk radio replying
with anti-semitic language and
conspiracy theories he researched Davis
Twitter account went back looked at
everything based on what he could tell
David lived in Oregon so he called the
LAN County Sheriff's Office in Oregon to
report this I don't think anybody in
Kalispell would have known about these
tweets but for mr. hudson reporting them
to law enforcement and convincing them
to investigated
Hudson contacted authorities in Orkin
before police figured out that Lenny oh
actually lived in Montana and police
took Lenny oh into custody the next day
the county charged him with two counts
defamation and intimidation
it was the defamation charge that caught
the attention of the UCLA law professor
Eugene Bullock in America persecutions
for let's say speech that expresses
racial religious hostility almost never
happened in large part because
prosecutors recognize that that kind of
speech is fully protected this is a rare
exception here for whatever reason the
prosecutor decided to push the envelope
and to argue the statute does apply to
this kind of thing but many people would
label hate speech Montana statute is so
broad that it outlaws speech that
subjects individuals or groups to hatred
contempt ridicule degradation or
disgrace the county argued that by
making statements such as the Holocaust
has been proven a lie Lenny o defamed
all Jewish people many statements about
groups and statements about history are
either themselves opinion or even if
they're in a sense factual assertions
they're nonetheless factual assertions
about the kind of historical or
scientific or religious or political
matters that we really need to have free
debate on I've been hearing over the
last several years lots of people
talking about hate speech they say well
is something free speech or is it hate
speech from a legal perspective that's
something like asking is something free
speech or is it unpatriotic speech well
it could be both but unpatriotic speech
is not a legally significant category
there's no First Amendment exception for
unpatriotic speech same with hate speech
the criminal defamation statute is
overly broad in two ways first is that
it doesn't define group class or
Association it could be any distinct
group of people then it could be people
named John it could be public defense
attorneys any group any size any way you
wanted to define it secondly actual
malice is generally required to find
someone guilty of defamation the Montana
court agreed dismissing the defamation
charge and ruling
the statute was overly broad and
infringed on constitutionally protected
speech I think it was a good decision I
think we do have to protect freedom of
speech the problem was that his speech
crossed the line into threats
intimidation under Montana law is that
their conscious intent is to cause
someone to either do something or not do
something under a threat Getty argues
that his client was just a frustrated
guy blowing off steam to a handful of
Twitter followers but rabbi Francine
Ralston thinks that Lenny o is a menace
who intended to harm her and others in
the community if you live in New York or
New Jersey where we lived and you say
you want to kill a rabbi it's not really
a specific threat there are hundreds of
thousands of rabbis all over the area if
you're in the Flathead Valley and you
say you want to put two in the head of a
rabbi and there are only two rabbis in
the entire Flathead Valley that's a
serious threat threats aren't protected
by the First Amendment but were Lenny
O's online rants rants that could have
easily washed away into the vast ocean
of online vitriol credible true threats
Lenny o had retrieved his guns from a
nearby storage facility a few days
before his arrest and he told police he
was pleased that his words had caused
them to beef up security at the local
schools one difficulty in the lenio case
is that while many of the threats were
very general about Jews generally some
of them talked about synagogues being
targeted such montana's not exactly
chock-full of synagogues from what I've
seen of the case I'm inclined to say
this probably wouldn't shouldn't be seen
as a punishable true threat but I do
think that that this book that's a much
closer question on the criminal
defamation question where there the
First Amendment argument was really very
solidly against that charge here
it's a closer issue and in a lot of
cases it's a closed issue I think
this is a very important case in the
country and if this speech is not
defined as threatening then I think were
in danger this is the only case that
I've had a crime reported in a nether
state that was ultimately prosecuted
here and I think that that is the
linchpin is that somebody has to be
threatened it would be the equivalent of
back in colonial days of somebody
yelling on a street corner
he's not directing these at anybody and
that's the biggest problem with the
state's case is that these are not
directed to a specific person